Hello Freak bitches left a fucking hole.
Just ate through his leg.
Fair to Lance.
What?
When it was snakes bite you,
that happens to you.
You have to sky got bit in the foot by
fair to Lance,
which means,
which by the way I believe means sort of
fire fell.
Denounce his French fell announced
that don't show sounds fell donelle so
sat both fell.
By the way,
Brian Cowen did several characters over
the time.
One of the reasons why I love going on
these trips at Brian is because it
becomes a giant five day comedy comes
the bride couch.
I'll do this my,
it's a captive audience.
You're not going anywhere.
You're going to go.
But it's also your style of humor.
It's like that's what you do.
Like when there's a group of guys around
all of a sudden,
I mean you would think that you would
get tired of gay jokes after five days.
No,
because he's got a bunch of different
gay characters in the Russian who makes
you eat salad for many days for reflux.
You in the ass.
Cause he wants your asshole clean.
I have clean asshole.
You have to,
we have to keep it clean,
clean.
Either just sell it.
I smack you this video of him explaining
to Steve Rinella what he wants Reno's
diet to be like.
Dodi's thinking about putting it online
like somehow or another.
Figuring out do it online,
do it an unnamed way.
It's mostly because I have you as an
audience and you're one of the best
laughers.
I just realized that after known you for
20 years.
I was like,
you know what?
I think he might be one of the greatest
laughers cause you,
you cackle you literally,
when you're laughing you literally go,
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
How funny.
I,
it's seductive to me.
I'm literally,
and then those guys or those guys are
such good audiences too.
Quintessential rock star with a
different spectrum than,
you know,
maybe not.
Not too,
I don't know.
You're being drug induced delirium and
going through the,
you know,
I think those dudes at that time had,
had probably been through enough to say,
I've seen,
I've been to the limit.
You know,
I've seen the edge of the cliff debt.
But that's the old adage like if you
suck enough,
uh,
Dick's,
one day you're going to want to have sex
with a woman.
Like if a gay guy gets to some breaking
point,
hundred million Dickson his ass and
mouth,
he's like enough blizzard of Dick Knopf,
please take it wasn't a woman.
Well it doesn't happen,
but does it happen the other way where a
man,
a straight man has so many different
female partners at one day he knew,
okay,
they fucked.
I want to be the guy that says,
I want to be the guy that says it a
little spoon.
If you're lying on someone's shoulder
and they put their arm around like that,
what you do is you reach up at the left
arm,
you protect the neck.
Very important
is that something like this?
You want to do it like this?
You want to cop it and don't let go of
that wrist,
pin it down to your chest.
Dead.
You gotta you got shrimp out.
I know you guys know about Hashtag
Hashtag trump out.
Oh man,
everybody,
it's so great.
So great at the show.
Sometimes people will just be like bad
shit.
It's like,
yeah.
So funny.
What a beautiful part of our history
here.
Joe Lou Reed.
Wasn't that Lou Reed?
David Bowie's God net worths Steve
Gutenberg.
David Bowie's Goddamn free lunch.
You know there was some study recently
about uh rehydrating and they were
talking about like how much more people
rehydrate if they're around things that
taste good.
Like if you have like sugary drinks,
like gatorade type drink,
like how much more you'll drink than if
it's just water,
right?
Yeah,
we're just gross.
We're gross.
Slovenly and sugars,
like those simple sugars,
like those are really not good for you
mean you didn't get away with eating
them after you work out because your
body is sorta glucose craving,
but the reality of those kinds of sports
drinks and stuff like that,
it's like this,
then I'll fucking healthy for you at
all.
This are corn syrup when liquid.
Yeah,
motherfuckers.
Well I think most of the sports drinks
or are owned by companies that produce
soft drinks.
Yeah,
I'm sure a lot of them are for sure.
A lot of them are for sure.
But they say the chocolate milk is the
best thing to drink right after your
workout.
Is that true?
I guess it depends who you talk to.
You and I,
I think this is based on some studies
that they've done,
but if you talk to anyone that's in the
Chinese medicine or like my wife's
really into Ayurvedic Medicine,
milk is the demon.
It's like,
what do they say?
They see it's drinking plus and then oak
is drinking pus.
How's it drinking?
Pus,
they hate milk.
Who are these people?
Well,
anybody.
Have they ever eaten cookies because
milk without cookies.
It's just bullshit.
Cookies without milk.
Crowded.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a lot of people into this method
of eating and you know,
eating for your body type and
everything.
And anyone that's a,
there's three things in Chinese medicine
that caused a lot of phlegm.
And in Chinese medicine,
phlegm is not only what you hack up when
you're exercising,
but also,
uh,
energy blockages in the system.
So the top of the list is dairy.
Uh,
second is peanuts.
In third or bananas,
you can't eat peanuts.
And you can't eat bananas.
No.
What kind of communist bullshit is this?
What are they trying to say?
Huh?
Bananas.
I know what the Fuck is wrong with
bananas,
man.
I don't know if I buy this Chinese
medicine shelf and I live the people
that brought you rhino horns for hard
ons.
Isn't that the same folk it is?
Uh,
yeah.
They do all sorts of crazy stuff.
How about tiger bone make you strong?
No,
it won't just kills fucking tiger.
Tom Ass.
Yeah.
So I take all this stuff with a grain of
salt.
You think back at some of the
misconceptions you had in your youth
about sex,
and it really is hilarious.
I was under the impression that you
needed what was called at the time a
scumbag,
which was a condom.
A rubber.
These are called that.
It was a condom.
That's where a scumbag comes from.
It was called a,
yeah.
A condom was a scumbag back in the old
days.
Wow.
And this was when I was a kid.
So I had never used that term.
But I heard my parents say that my dad's
friends,
you know?
Yeah.
I didn't have a scumbag last night,
so shit like that.
I know.
It's hilarious.
So I thought you needed one to get a
girl pregnant.
I thought the shit that was on it got
the girl pregnant.
Yeah.
And uh,
and I thought you had a fucker in the
ass.
Like I didn't know that there was a
vagina.
I just thought,
you know,
is an ass you've so you fucker in the
ass.
Why with a condom and she has a kid,
why
you off?
But the fucked up thing is now I fucked
girls don't want to have a kid so I
don't wear a condom and I fucked him on
the policy.
So it did have some kind of an influence
on my future when I was in high school,
and I don't remember where I learned
this or if it was taught in class,
but I specifically remember something
where it was,
it was like a real source where they
were saying that in order for a woman to
get pregnant that she has to have an
orgasm.
Because when a woman has an orgasm,
it opens up the canal and the eggs get
through.
I remember like there's been some just
ridiculously ignorant shit that I was
taught.
Yeah,
that is,
I,
I would,
I would think may because of the
moisture,
you know,
it gives a little more fluid for the
sperm cells to swim up,
but it was like a door was only good at
anyway,
like tall planing it,
like a door was opening.
There's like 1980s healthcare shit.
I Dunno if they didn't know back then or
they just,
it was an older even textbook where they
were just ridiculous.
That sounds like something you'd tell a
girl,
like,
so you could come in there,
look,
I won't give you an Oregon.
You'll be fine.
As long as they don't make you calm when
I'm making any payments.
And then after I come,
I'll make you come.
Nothing better than that.